hello and welcome to Marshall matters
with me Winston Marshall at The
Spectator on this podcast I've been
exploring freedom of speech and taboo
topics in the creative industry well it
seems to me there is no more totemic and
taboo a topic than the trans debate so
to explore the trans issue I am joined
by Britain Edison Economist and author
of trans Helen Joyce Helen thank you so
much thanks for inviting me in
um so Hardball question yep to start off
is a trans woman a woman of course not
we all know what woman means woman means
that you were conceived female you got
born and you grew up you didn't die
before you grew up that's the only
Criterion for being a one so then what
is all that's about
well some people would like to redefine
the words man and woman to mean well I
don't know what quite what they think
they mean because I've spent years
thinking about it and I can't make it
work maybe social roles maybe they think
there are social roles man and woman and
that a man can play the social role of a
woman I've never heard anything with
sexist in my life
I don't think that I play the social
role of a woman I just think I am a
woman and everything I do is a thing
that a woman does just by definition
and I've done some very manly things in
my life I have a PhD in mathematics
for example I'm also a mother
I don't think that makes me some mixture
of masculine and feminine I think I'm
just a woman who you know did some
relatively unconventional things as well
as some quite conventional things
some people want to be the opposite sex
and I think that a lot of this started
by a misplaced kindness uh the desire to
accommodate people
and when there were very few of them
that maybe didn't seem like such a big
deal
like we don't worry about witness
protection you know and we forceify all
sorts of things for people in witness
protection but they're just such a tiny
number and there's a reason to do it
so when they were very very very very
very tiny number of people who wanted to
have surgery and try and pass as the
opposite sex doesn't matter but now
we're in a situation where several
percent of young people say that they
are not identifying within the gender
binary or that their Trends or their
non-binary they're gender fluid and and
then they want to move around in a world
that does have certain things separated
by sex then it is a problem you know
that a man just says I feel like a woman
today I'm going into the women's toilets
I mean Eddie's ordinary uses the women's
toilets does he he does yeah and and uh
are you worried about does that concern
you of course it's not private I don't
think any men should be in the women's
toilets so I don't care if they're
putting on lipstick or a skirt they
still shouldn't be in the women's
toilets right now part of this and it
seems to me uh about definition of words
and one word that has many definitions
is gender and I want to understand
what where the word gender comes from
and why it's being differentiated from
sex now I think I have the answer to
this but perhaps and I think you express
this very well in articulate this in
your in your book but perhaps you can
break this down the difference between
sex and gender
so sex is reproductive roles and that
doesn't mean that you're fertile it
doesn't mean you've actually been a
parent doesn't mean that you know you're
still at the fertile point of your life
or anything but it's a body plan it's a
body plan that was designed by Evolution
to support either the male or female
role in reproduction or mammals come in
male and female most plants and animals
do too only like you know little
single-celled organisms that just split
don't
and male means that the whole organism
or the body part was uh created in such
a way like by Evolution that it supports
the production of small motile gametes
that we call sperm in humans
and female means it's eggs
and those are two reproductive
strategies and those things shape your
whole body like everything in a man's
body and everything in a woman's body
has been optimized by Evolution to
support those two reproductive roles
so where did gender come from then well
the word used to mean just a grammatical
thing like you know gender was in
grammar whether it was a masculine or
feminine word and I mean that doesn't
necessarily mean to do with male and
female like the word for girl in German
is a masculine word in Ireland the same
with Colleen the word for girl is a I
think it's neuter it's not female anyway
um and then it got sort of co-opted into
meaning these social roles and the way
we're socialized into being masculine or
feminine but this is a co-option by uh
by feminists by famously and they were
they were trying to separate out the
idea that you know a woman had to be
feminine in the famous phrase of Simone
de Beauvoir she said uh one's not born
but becomes a woman and she didn't mean
that a man can become a woman she meant
as girls female children are socialized
into being woman that you're not able to
just grow up and be yourself
you're forced into you know Beauty
rituals subservience you know the mirror
to men that sort of thing and there's an
awful lot of Truth to that and of course
there's an equivalent process of
socialization for boys and men you don't
cry be tough you know don't show if you
feel pain be ready to fight those sorts
of
things
and they're not totally divorced from
biological reality these roles
like there's not nothing not totally
divorce no of course not because I mean
you know obviously they're not at all no
some of them are I mean things like
which color is a boy color or a girl
color that's just arbitrary right you
know so some things about gender are
quite arbitrary the fact that dancing in
our culture is seen as a feminine thing
to do in many cultures it's done
exclusively by men so some some gender
things are absolutely in positions and
the idea that you know that uh women are
there to reflect back the man believe
you me it doesn't look like that from
this side but that is a gendered
expectation so for second wave feminists
I think they went too far in saying that
it was all socialization sure but a lot
of it is and it's very interesting and
productive to look and see which bits
are actually tied to how people are how
we behave towards people who are gender
non-conforming because even the bits
that are connected with or being male or
female some people are very very
atypical for their sex
and how how good are we at accommodating
those people you know if you're a very
flamboyant somewhat flaming gay man
how do you fit into your culture if
you're super Butch lesbian how do you
fit into your culture culture you know
but then it became this idea of gender
identity which was
something more inner like an essence
um and I it's odd that this happened
because the person who cited most often
Judith Butler
saw it as a performance she saw it as an
extremely external and superficial thing
she said gender is what you do
and she denied any sort of natural
substrate to it at all she just thought
that they were the things that got
reality because they were done over and
over again famously she said that they
are in imitations without Originals what
does that mean oh it means that like
it's totally arbitrary what men and
women do in our culture completely
arbitrary but it's just done over and
over again okay and that's what made it
masculine and feminine and she believes
that you could disrupt it by drag or by
you know being deliberately gender and
unconforming by querying the boundaries
this sort of thing but somehow she's
still cited by people who seem to
believe that it's an Inner Essence and I
mean the more
I don't know the more trivial of these
people seem to think that it's like a
pink brain in a blue body or a blue
brain in a pink body I mean these are
the drawings that used to be done for
children yeah a couple years ago by the
translobby groups like they would
literally show a little outline of a
child pink you know with a blue brain
and say this child you know has a boy
gender identity trapped in a girl's body
is this the concept of a sexed soul yeah
that's what I've called it
um I mean if you say that they'll say no
no it's much more subtle than that but
if you look at the teaching materials
that are going to schools that's exactly
what they're saying I mean as soon as
you say that a man could be a woman
either you mean the social roles see I
mean if you target himself up and wears
makeup and high heels and tatters around
the place saying yes sir he's become a
woman or you mean he feels like a woman
and that makes him a woman like there
are no other options so I know there's a
as you cite the the post-modernist uh
history that's that's shaped the course
of of this philosophy but is there a
science to uh people who have gen
dysphoria what's what do we understand
about that scientifically so gender
dysphoria is the experience of being
deeply uncomfortable with the fact of
your sex
um hard to imagine I suppose unless
you've experienced it so I can't be more
precise than that
I mean
the latest iteration of trans ideology
doesn't require gender dysphoria for the
idea that your trends like it says some
people have no gender dysphoria they
just know that they are non-binary or
they know that they're members of the
opposite sex
so they have left that behind even but
if we for a moment just answer the
question you know what is gender
dysphoria
it doesn't mean you're a member of the
opposite sex you know like how could it
it just means you're unhappy being the
sex you are in some way so what's gender
dysphoria it's the next question you
might ask yourself well I would say that
it's a largely socially created illness
so that's true of most mental conditions
that they are some mixture of a
predisposition life history but also how
Society interprets what's happened to
you so if you think of something like
anorexia
if you could look back through history
there have always been occasional people
who have settled on self-starvation as a
way to express their discomfort or their
you know
hatred of their lives or as a response
to a society they see as just unbearable
you know it's rare and then it it sort
of became the done the done way to
express your misery if you were a young
American Girl American teenage girl in
say the 1970s or 80s but it was still
unusual elsewhere and sociologists of
medicine have tracked how the media
spread that idea in other cultures and
so the cases of anorexia arise like
really arise from almost nothing to very
large numbers
so that this is actually something that
uh happened in Hong Kong until 1993 or
1994 there are very few cases of
anorexia and and they weren't and they
weren't experienced the typical way that
we think of anorexia so the version of
anorexia you and I have been taught
involves a distorted body image you know
the girl who's starving away still looks
in the mirror and sees herself as fat
the few kids who were starving
themselves in Hong Kong before that
period knew perfectly well what size
they were
they just tended to say I I feel I can't
eat I feel I have a constriction and
when you looked at their back history it
wasn't about you know unrealistic
images of women and the media or indeed
even miserable personal circumstances
that had changed recently like a family
divorce or something they didn't want to
live yeah their lives were completely
empty and they didn't want to live so
they starved but they were tiny numbers
and then one of these girls died and she
died in a public place on her way to
school so it was very shocking and it
was widely reported and the media
looking for ways to report it obviously
you know you're starting to be able to
search for things online they found
American reports of self-starvation and
they interpreted what had happened for
the Hong Kong population through that
lens and that became the way that Hong
Kong girls also expressed their misery
and and the numbers completely
skyrocketed by hundreds of times yeah
you know from like a couple of year to
you know several dozen a week at the
same special the same specialist you
know so so gender dysphoria I think is
like that I think there are rare
individuals who spontaneously land on
the idea
that what's wrong with their lives and
what's wrong with them is that they were
born in the wrong body they were all
sick so they're really meant to be the
opposite sex or some version of that but
now that's the narrative for pretty much
all disease for children so we're
creating gender dysphoria yes this is
something that Carl Jung called a
psychic endemic that's right and uh
there's a superb book by Abigail
schreier called irreversible damage
which explores this specific issue and
how young girls are getting stuck down
YouTube wormholes and it's convincing
them that they're not only that they
have gender dysphoria but the the way to
treat the gender dysphoria is to have
irreversible treatment it's a great book
I really admire Abigail for writing it
and you know she wrote it because she
wrote one column for the Wall Street
Journal
on some of these issues and was
absolutely astonished by the answers and
the response that she got from readers
so lots of people wrote to her parents
saying please look into this more write
more about this this has happened to my
daughter I'm told I'm a bigot for saying
that you know she wasn't but I don't
believe this nonsense about her really
being a boy and
and she started to look into it more and
then realized that nearly every
specialist journalist in health or
social science or you know equality or
any of the things you might imagine
would look into it have been scared off
it by the response so that's why she
wrote her book and I would say even
since writing that book the shape of
gender dysphoria has mutated among that
group like it's because we can tell that
this is a psychic Contagion
in part by how fast it's changing
so every sort of few months it's new
gender identities like it's much less
common now to say that you're a trans
boy now you say you're a non-binary or
gender fluid or a demi-boy and you it's
less Demi boy well we're a bit boyish
don't worry I mean why are you asking me
it's nonsense is what it is
the idea of this being how you spend
your teens inventing micro identities
it's quite sad it could be a lot more
fun than this it could be a lot more fun
yeah now despite your frustration uh
there is someone I call progress legally
uh as we speak mermaids which is a group
advising teenagers
um has just had their trusty Dr Jacob
Breslow resigned because he was he spoke
at before you act conference in 2011
which would cause for pedophiles to have
the right to live in truth and dignity
and also calls pedophiles minor
attracted persons and having gone on
their website this morning they've
closed down their phone lines uh because
of the Intolerable abuse quote that
they've been receiving as a consequence
they have also they are a group that
have enjoyed the support of Megan and
Harry as well as actor actress Emma
Watson
what can you tell me about mermaids and
of course there's a legal proceedings at
the moment where they have been taking
LGB Alliance to court uh disputing the
lgba uh being a charity what's your take
on the mermaids organization so mermaids
were set up oh gosh more than 20 years
ago
um by some parents as a little self-help
group and it was a good group then so
this is before the transcontagion really
got going
and there were just a few dozen children
a year seen in the gender clinics
uh but it's very a very difficult
experience like it's very hard to cope
with something that hardly anyone's
coping with so they found each other and
supported each other and they were quite
sensible like they shared good you know
there's very little research but what
there was they shared it and they
supported each other and if you look
back at the way back machine you look at
their early website and you know they
weren't crazy
they were you know talking about the
reality of sex bodies they weren't
suggesting that a child who had gender
dysphoria thereby was a member of the
opposite sex or anything everything
changed for them when a woman called
Susie Green became one of the parents
and so Susie has done a TED talk about
her experience and her husband's
experience with their child Jackie who's
a boy who was a highly effeminate little
boy
um
and they found it difficult in
particular that a father found it
difficult having such an effeminate
little boy because he didn't want a gay
son
and so they went to family counseling
and I don't think Susie was that
bothered by it but the father definitely
was and what they were advised was that
they should they had to hang together
the two of them had to make a decision
and stick with it and they decided that
this little boy was actually a girl that
was the decision and they transitioned
to Jackie socially
meaning changing name pronouns letting
this child's hair grow long telling
everyone it's a girl
wearing girls clothes that sort of thing
and then you know puberty approaches
obviously that is pretty shocking in
terms of homophobic I mean a lot of it
is homophobia but this is conversion
therapy quiet well this is a whole other
level of conversions and now I'm not
saying that all the kids who identify as
trans are same-sex attracted but
historically speaking in the 50 to 70
years that we've seen kids at all being
looked at by gender doctors most of them
were interesting most of the because
there is a strong link and this is back
to your question about gender there is a
strong link between being gender
non-conforming and growing up gay
is by no means 100 there are plenty of a
link or correlation a strong correlation
very strong like 20 or 25 times more
likely to grow up gay if you're highly
highly gendered and conforming to the
extent that the people around you would
notice yes compared to the general
population that said there are still
plenty of sweet little boys who love
ballet who grow up to be straight and
you know girls who can't stand Thrills
and want to be climbing trees and love
football and so on but just numbers wise
there's a strong correlation so most of
the kids who saw the early gender
doctors there were very few of those
kids but most of them were same-sex
attracted when they passed puberty and
the first studies which tracked the kids
but didn't do any interventions and that
almost all those kids stopped saying I
want to be a boy or I want to be a girl
or I think I really am a girl
they just accept themselves as gay
puberty taught them who they were but
that process was foreclosed for Jackie
Greene um who has transitioned at age
four
and Susie found um at the time there was
no there was no transition pathway on
the NHS Susie reached out to American
doctors
and got puberty blockers from a chap
called Norman's bank at the Boston
Children's Hospital
and blocked Jackie's puberty
I think probably around age 11 and then
at age 13 or 14 Jackie was put on
estrogen and then they flew to Thailand
and got Jackie what's called um gender
reassignment surgery meaning genital
surgery on his 16th birthday
so that was when he was castrated and
had a near vagina created
[Music]
that's all about 13 14 years ago I think
maybe a little less and Susie is now
the chair of mermaids and has been for a
long time and that's the pathway that
mermaids promotes and so anyone who
didn't agree with that pathway is no
longer in mermaids and it's it's
entirely people who believe that this is
that you know children can be born in
the wrong body you would socially
transition a child who was born in the
wrong body you would do the surgery you
would you know they pushed very hard for
that treatment pathway on the NHS and
they succeeded in getting it too it was
their pressure that really stopped the
Tavistock which is the NHS clinic for
gender dysphoric children that stopped
the Tavistock from being so cautious
so mermaids really led the NHS down that
path so that they're they're
recommending puberty blockers to
Children their path they recommend this
what they call gender affirmative
pathway okay which which really
presupposes that if a child says to you
I'm really a boy or I'm really a girl
that child knows what they're talking
about and means it and that it's going
to last in such a way that you would
really take these steps now in case it's
not obvious these steps sterilize you
they probably mean that you'll have no
sex life as well
and we don't know what puberty blockers
do to your brain but you may remember
being a teenager Lots changes in your
brain in your teens like it's the second
major developmental Sprint after
babyhood so just disturbing it is to say
the least a risky thing to do
so mermaids has a lot of money now it
became quite a fashionable charity it
got like all these people like Emma
Watson and Harry and Megan supporting it
and it got a half a million over a few
years from the national lottery and it
grew to be quite a large charity I mean
not an enormous charity but like you
know quite sizable and they produce
produce teaching materials and they
train teachers and there's a notorious
video of a mermaid's trainer teaching
teachers using what they called a gender
scale which had a picture of a Barbie
doll and a picture of a GI Joe and in
between these sort of mannequins
morphing from pink with pigtails to a
big Butch thing in Black you know in
between the two and telling teachers
they should encourage children to place
themselves in this gender scale and work
out who they were which can only mean
that you look at this and if you're not
Barbie or GI Joe you wonder are you
really a boy or a girl do we know how
far into into schools that this got from
mermaids particularly I think they
trained in several dozen schools and
that went out but there's a set of these
Charities there's a constellation of
them gendered intelligence the proud
trust stone wall do this sort of stuff
to mermaids this is the sort of thing
that goes into all schools now lots of
councils got help in drawing up their
trans inclusion policies and their RSE
lessons from people like mermaids so
it's been incredibly influential so this
this is the stuff that's being taught to
children and then we wonder why there's
an increase in gender dysphoria telling
children if you don't feel like Barbie
or GI Joe you might have gender
dysphoria you might be trans like we're
actually suggest selling trans
identities to children in schools
so mermaids has this self mythology that
they are very under pressure from
transphobes of course they would think
I'm a transfer folk the first time I
ever looked for mermaids on Twitter I
was already blocked and that was before
I wrote my book so they they don't
accept any challenge they don't talk to
journalists who aren't totally
uncritical they're like an organization
Under Siege
that's not good for transparency and
it's not the way that you should run a
charity you should be using you know
absolute maximum transparency and that
sort of very um responsible situation
with very vulnerable beneficiaries for
your charity
so this is Jacob Breslow guy yeah I mean
he hasn't been a trustee for very long
but I mean the way it's been reported is
as if you know back in 2011 he made this
lapse
since then he's been a student at um lse
and done a PhD and now he's one of the
people running he's an associate
professor there and he runs courses and
the courses are all about queer queering
childhood
so he supervised a thesis last year um
in which a student gave a presentation
of this paper and it was saying you know
tariffs that's trans exclusionary
radical feminists people like me who
think sex is real you know tariffs are
scared of trans people well I [ __ ]
hope they're scared I'll hold the knife
to your throat and whisper in your ear
are you scared I sure hope so like this
sort of stuff this is Jacob breslow's
work and the queering the pedagogy stuff
is this idea that childhood is like male
or female
socially constructed category which it
kind of is
but only kind of same way that man and
woman are kind of
socially constructed on top of a
substration that's real
but the queer theorists think it's all
just words it's all just The Superficial
stuff and so what his thesis is about
and he's about he's writing a book at
the moment and it has their queer
children as one of the chapters or queer
childhood it's all about
disrupting this idea of childhood
innocence
um
thinking about the boundaries between
children and adults and you can see how
I'm trying to pick my words very
carefully and you can see how this could
be done with good intentions but you can
also see how it would be done with very
nefarious intentions I mean this is
absolutely where the pedophiles of today
are is in this queer pedagogy queer
queering childhood stuff and not just
today because and you write about this
in your book there's a history of a link
between the the with pedophile groups or
I don't know quite how to what language
to use but simple things like Pro
pedophile I guess I mean Pro lowering
the age of consent Pro
conceptualizing of pedophilia as a
sexual orientation which by the way it
might be
but that doesn't mean it's right like it
could be the world's most unfortunate
sexual orientation and that it's a
sexual orientation you're not allowed to
act on but that's probably where they're
coming from it is it is I mean I I I
have a lot of sympathy with people who
are born with um conditions or urges
that mean they can't you know be
comfortably accommodated in society
because I'm a massive bleeding heart I
know they don't think I am but I am
um so I'm really really sorry for
somebody who might feel that they have
urges that are totally unacceptable I'm
starting to believe that we can't even
study this because as soon as we try and
study this the bloody pedophiles come in
but you think to yourself like let's
find out are some people born pedophile
what can you do how do you work with
them can I cure them and then the
blooming pedophiles come in
yeah I mean I'm not sure how much
sympathy I have for example a man might
have an urge to kiss a very beautiful
woman yeah but then that there's no
sympathy I don't know our poor guy can't
kiss her no don't because I told you I'm
a bleeding heart
and let's take
position here
suppose you just don't find adults of
either sex at all attractive you're
never going to have a decent sex life
and you're never going to form a proper
relationship or else you're going to be
doing something unconscionable that's
your choice
I think that's a bit sad and I'd like to
know more about it can we help these
people are they born that way whatever
but it seems to me that every time we
try to study this in computer files and
start saying well if people are born
this way it's another sexuality minor
attracted persons blah blah so to say
the least Jacob breslow's work should
have suggested that at no point was he
remotely suitable to work with the
children's charity agreed
um
to say the least but also I would like
to know whether mermaids reached out to
him because that's how it normally works
for charities
it's not like you put an ad in the paper
and so we want we want trustees you
reach out to people I think they liked
his
um quite violent rhetoric towards
tariffs this is absolutely not like an
ordinary properly run charity that's
just made one little mistake about
somebody who was at a dodgy conference
in 2011. this is indicative of a world
view right so my earlier point was that
things seem to be at least in Britain
making uh a turn legally for what you
might call the better with mermaids
coming apart uh you mentioned my Force
data and there's of course Alison Bailey
the Barrister who was a co-founder of
the LGB Alliance who have both been
proved under the equality act 2010 in
court that their uh beliefs of gender
critical beliefs are protected beliefs
so it seems now legally and of course
the Tavistock which mermaids were
influencing have been told this summer
to close by Spring next year tavista
talk had been advising children to get
surgery without parental consent puberty
blockers and
um perhaps much more but it would seem
despite these things that happened but
things that are perhaps turning for the
better are you hopeful yes I think so I
mean I will just say a little bit about
the Tavistock um the Tavistock doesn't
actually do things over parental consent
it has fairly strict rules about when
um when you would take puberty blockers
when you would take cross-sex hormones
when you would have surgery it does have
age limits for these things it has never
acted without parental consent because
gender dysphoria it's it's so it's so
ineffable you know like there are no
criteria for us that aren't things that
can be seen outside like that the child
is miserable or that the child's you
know persistently
you know claims that they are members
the opposite sex what it was doing
was
basically being quite unquestioning and
very very patchy by the way like
incredibly different like it had this
big increase in numbers you know some
therapists were better than others but
if a parent said no I'm not having much
I'll go down this pathway the Tavistock
to not push for them to the good law
project Jolie and Mormons
um
project let's say uh that took a court
case to establish that the children
could consent
um without parental consent
and that was established in court
actually but I don't think the Tavistock
was doing it they certainly didn't want
to okay but so I would say that it was a
poorly run poorly managed overburdened
um service that had allowed itself to be
pushed around by activists
um it is being closed down because a
review is being done of gender services
in the NHS for children by Hillary Cass
is a very eminent pediatrician and she
looked at us in her interim report which
was published this year the final report
is due out next year and she said that
this service was not safe too
overburdened too long waiting lists very
patchy and poor treatment too little
consideration of other problems
and she said that gender shouldn't be
hived off like this like this one
Specialist Clinic to see gender
dysphoric kids only makes sense when you
have a few dozen of them a year or
maximum a couple of hundred but now that
you know there's a half a dozen kids in
every class and every school saying that
they're Trends I exaggerate only very
slightly
well how much are you exaggerating that
I I think in about a six-month time I
won't be exaggerating at all it's
there's this incredible increase
this this Autumn when kids went back to
school so many of them
have identified as trans we're hearing
from parents all the time
saying what happened you know let her
home from the school or indeed just
discovered by chance when it's when it's
everywhere you would just deal with it
and with all your other Mental Health
Services which is basically what Hillary
cast has recommended because the people
that they've been seeing at the
Tavistock the children they've been
seeing at the Tavistock they're
um they're very high degree of
comorbidities that means other issues
yes so self-harm autistic Spectrum
and depression Eating Disorders family
traumas
um child abuse and a very large number
of them same-sex attracted as I said you
know since so saying that you're just
going to look at their gender makes no
sense like if a kid comes into you and
they've been cutting and they're clearly
unwell and you get the feeling that this
child is depressed you would want to do
a full workup really and the gender
issues maybe you should just park them
but that's not what happens in a gender
clinic so that was her recommendation
can you tell me about the equality act
2010 because it seems that it's it's a
double-edged sword because on the one
hand it's been used to exonerate Alison
Bailey as I mentioned and Maya Foster
your friend but on the other hand
um I think it was Kardashian Cardiff
University that allows uh trans gender
or transsexuals to use the toilet of
their choosing and they cite the
equality at 2010 because it's a
protective belief so what's the is is
the equality act
what's going on there it's a bit of a
jumble I I'm basically a fan of the
equality act which puts me at odds with
the current government with whom more in
sympathy in general
um on trans issues than I would be with
labor and lib Dems so the way the
equality act works is it was passed in
2010 as a sort of a tidying up a big
overarching law that brought together
about 100 pieces of legislation and case
law that had developed over the previous
decades there are nine protected
characteristics and what that basically
means is they're things that you're not
allowed to discriminate on the basis of
except when you need to I know that
sounds odd but what I mean if I take an
example um
let's see age
you can't discriminate on age means that
you couldn't have a job ad that says you
know young bar keeper required
but you are allowed to for example have
a playground that says under tens only
because the kids can't play if the
teenagers are hanging out on the swings
but you're not so you're not so there's
there's lawful and unlawful
discrimination and that's the framework
that's the way you think about it sex is
one of the protected characteristics and
it means male or female so you can't
advertise and say we want a secretary
female only or you know
there's sex discrimination is obviously
a big one but you could for example do a
program in an inner city school that you
know you identified that it was the
white working class boys who were behind
and reading so you do a special course
for them because it's it's in the
service of more equality basically so so
I think the equality Act is quite a good
way to look at these things
so badly miscited and never more than
when it comes to sex because another of
the protected characteristics is gender
reassignment
and that's this prop that is it's an odd
definition it's something like proposing
to undergo undergoing or having
undergone any process of a site
reassigning your sex characteristics
that's not quite right but it's
something like that it's anybody who
thinks themselves as trans very vague no
criteria you don't have to be in the
care of a doctor or anything like that
and if it's just well you can't
discriminate against them I'm all for
that you know some bloke turns up at
work in a skirt and you know lipstick
and nail polish and you know says he's
changed his name to Susie I don't want
him to be fired I also don't want him
using the women's toilets because he's
not a woman
okay yeah so that's that's the mistake a
lot of these places think that if you
have the protected characteristic of
gender reassignment your sex has changed
but actually they're two separate
characteristics so Cardiff University is
just making a mistake there as are all
the other universities because that's
not unusual and the reason they're
making that mistake is because of the
lobby groups like Stonewall and mermaids
that have systematically misrepresented
the equality act in their training
materials in their schemes for employers
you know they have these very
influential schemes like the um the
workplace equality index from Stonewall
you sign up and they come and they Mark
you basically and then you get a badge
and it says like we're great and one of
the ways that you'll show you're great
is by letting the men use the women's
toilets if they say they're women I'm
not I'm not exaggerating that is one of
the ways they'll say you're great
and they want you to get rid of gender
language you know to your maternity
policy would say you know parent or
birthing parent yeah
just in case it wasn't already obvious
what is wrong with having a trans woman
in a toilet for women I mean the
language is straight away misleading
isn't it you know when people when you
say trans woman you think it's some sort
of woman but it's men
and it could be a man who looks like you
I mean there are no criteria and even if
it's a man who's dressed in the women's
clothes and so on I'm not blind I can
see who's a man
and the reason we have single sex
toilets I mean it's three reasons safety
dignity and privacy I was in them uh
Edinburgh yesterday for the protests
against the Scottish government's plans
to introduce gender self-id and
afterwards we went for a meal lunch
and it was in a pub and the pub had
mixed sex toilets it just had one
toilets you went in and okay so each of
the individual cubicles did have a
full-length door and the um sink was
inside so you think like it's a single
it's a single facility but it's all
behind one door and it comes out onto a
narrow corridor
with I think it was eight doors opening
onto it
do you remember how Larry men can get in
pubs
do you know what men do in to women in
poems do you know what teenage girls
have to put up with
this is not safe this is not safe a pub
that does this sort of toilet design is
putting women in danger women go to
toilets to get away from men sometimes
and then there's just a privacy issue
you know like if your period has started
and
you know you've bled or something if you
deal with it and miscarriages commonly
happen in women's toilets they don't
tend to wait until you're at home you
know
um and then there are women who have
special or particular needs so um you're
disabled you need to be helped into the
toilet you don't want to do that like
like I imagine a woman who needs
somebody to help her an elderly woman
say in this space
if it's a women's toilet you can leave
the door open to the individual cubicle
another one will be really nice about it
and they'll just give you a bit of
privacy there was no possibility of that
here and what about a Muslim woman or an
Orthodox Jewish woman who can't do
certain things into close proximity with
men
you know women take longer to use the
toilets we need about half as many
toilets again as men do toilet sales are
such a trivial thing and it's because
healthy young people like you instant
who do podcasting and who do journalism
and so on they imagine themselves they
haven't been afraid they're mostly men
they haven't been afraid in a in a pub
but they haven't had to go and hide in
the toilet and get their phone out and
ring a friend to come and get them
because there's some weird guy outside
you know men will follow women into
toilets if they can
when they try and get away from them in
perhaps and now they've got an excuse
that man you can't challenge him because
he could say he's a woman
so the toilet seems like you know you
could be quite relaxed about toilets but
you wouldn't be relaxed maybe about say
changing rooms or rate crisis centers or
whatever no toilets are really important
people don't go out unless they can use
safe dignified clean private spaces oh
by the way men piss on the seat I'd
really really really rather I wasn't
using a toilet that lots of men have
been using all day on behalf of all men
I apologize that is disgusting it is
disgusting but lots
then pissing this in the in the sinks as
well if there's a if there's no toilet
free you know this I saw your face yeah
I don't want this happening in my
toilets so sometimes people say this
thing about it you know there's a
gender-neutral toilet at home but that's
not used by several hundred men in a day
that I don't know so where the
transactors would take umbrage with this
argument I think is that they would say
that this is accusing uh trans
agendas of behaving like this and they
said you're not a transgender wouldn't
behave like this and and well a trans a
trans woman is just a man there's no
other Criterion for being a trans woman
then that your male it used to be that
um you would not consider using the
women's toilets unless you were under
the care of a gender doctor like in the
1980s and 90s the doctors would give you
a letter in case women challenged you in
the toilet and you would get out of this
letter that says aha you know I'm being
seen by a doctor and I'm in the process
of transitioning I don't think women
liked that very much but it was a very
tiny number of people
and women still felt free to say you
shouldn't be here now you can't you
can't challenge anyone like there are
signs that you see sometimes in toilets
that say all genders or they say does
someone here look like they shouldn't be
here
you don't know what gender someone is by
looking don't ask so it just means any
man I'm not saying anything particular
about men who identify as trans I'm just
saying they're men that's all
um so you mentioned that you're in
Scotland yep tell me about the Scottish
gender bill yeah okay so there are two
relevant laws for the question of who's
Trends one of them we've talked about
the equality act that doesn't really set
criteria it's just if you say you're
trans you are there's a much much tinier
group of people who've used the terms of
an earlier law the gender recognition
Act of 2004 to to change the sex that's
on their birth certificate to do that
you had to go to a doctor get a
diagnosis of gender dysphoria get a
signature from another doctor fill in a
form pay five pounds and that's
considered by a panel but basically
approve it pretty much always but then
you get a thing called a gender
recognition certificate and that allows
you to get a new birth search that says
the sex that you're not on it
there's no particular criteria for
surgery or anything like that
so if you're imagining like I think
people listening to debates about trans
issues they often imagine somebody who's
basically indistinguishable from a
member of the opposite sex but like no
you could just look like anyone else of
your sex but now your birthstone says
you're the opposite sex
on the other hand it's bit bureaucratic
so not many people do it
Scotland plans to make it very easy that
you adjust oh sorry you have to wait two
years as well I forgot that that's the
important Criterion here
wait two years to so between applying
and getting your gender recognition
certificate takes two years at the
moment at the moment Scotland wants to
bring that down to three months it wants
to basically make it just that you say
you want it no doctor no diagnosis of
gender dysphoria as low as age 16. so
basically they're just opening up to a
much much larger group of people
with no criteria or checks of any sort
like you could be you could actually be
a rapist and apply for this yes and then
you would legally count in more
situations as a member of the opposite
sex so for example if you're imprisoned
it'd be rather hard to send you to a
prison that's for your own sex well this
is uh this actually the the Crux of this
um it's an argument you make very well
in your book and it's related to prisons
but it's uh I'd like to ask you about
that but it's actually about the the
propensity for violence that men have as
opposed to as to women and that and that
is the problem with the toilet bill
that's the the the problem with
um what's going on in prisons Now in
America if I'm not mistaken in New
Jersey uh a man identifying as a woman
just raped and impregnated two women in
a prison and uh this was earlier this
year but uh and you make the case
in your book and this is uh I'm gonna
I'm gonna read your book if you don't
mind because I think this is fine by one
argument the far greater number of male
prisoners and their far greater
propensity for violent and sexual crimes
mean that not very many males will need
to seek transfer before women's prisons
are overwhelmed if the UK prisons
inspectorate is right and two percent of
male prisoners identify as women that is
a figure greater than half the total
number of female prisoners and if trans
women's offending pattern is male
typical and the share imprisoned for sex
crimes is five times as high as for
women you arrive at a startling
conclusion
of all the sex offenders behind bars in
both men's and women's prisons who
identify as women well over two-thirds
are male
it's hard to keep track of
and so I'll sort of I'll talk through
the numbers there are about 88 000
people in prison in England and Wales
four thousand are women so 84 000 in one
bucket and four thousand in the other
now of those 84 000 nearly 20 are in for
a sex crime
of the four thousand only four percent
so just like so it's five times and then
five times again is the difference okay
if you're looking just at sex crimes and
then if you analyze the sex crimes most
of the sex crimes the men commit are
rape sexual assault whatever the women
it's mostly accessory or um non-contact
crimes so that's things like helping
with child porn obviously a very bad
crime but not making you a risk to other
actual adults around you so there's only
a really a handful of women who commit
violence
sex offenses like on the person each
year and their attempt there's what
about 20 000 men and that's just the
ones we know about like if the other men
in jail lots of them will be sex
criminals as well because rape is very
underreported and so on
so you've tens and tens of thousands of
men
and a couple hundred women who commit
these sorts of crimes then on top of
that you've got the fact that men are
much stronger than women the differences
are large especially in the upper body
and then you would think that you're
going to allow one of these men to say
he's a woman and put him in the women's
prisons
and the violence difference between men
and women and the types of crimes
difference means the prisons are
different as well there are no high
security women's prisons there's only
medium and low security
and they're generally much more
home-like places like the problem one of
the women I know in Scotland a woman
called her own a Hotchkiss she's a
retired prison governor
the problems in a women's prison are the
women are self-harming depressed almost
all of them have been victims of
domestic violence rape they're in for
prostitution
um non-payment of fines shoplifting the
people with very chaotic and miserable
lives and they're very very often people
whose lives have been destroyed by their
relations with men I'm not saying it's
all the men's fault I'm just saying
that's the way it is they're shitty
boyfriends they had a pimp
you know they ran away from some bloke
who was hitting them and life went
downhill after that that's women's
prisons they're very sad places you
don't tend to have to worry about fights
or anything like that
men's prisons are very different like
you know there's those 20 of committed
sex crimes but then there's a lot of
other violent crimes as well there's a
lot of violence in men's prisons
um
they're just really very different
places and then you get these men who
say they're women I mean we you know we
don't have good data on these things but
of the trans identifying male prisoners
that we know about half of them have
committed sex crimes not 20 have
either they're taking you know advantage
of a stupid policy or there's something
about being a trans woman that makes you
more likely than other men to be a sex
criminal I don't think it's the second
one I think it's the first I think it's
the lacks policy so no men belong in
women's prisons they really don't
there's a lot of vulnerable men in men's
prisons who have to be managed and
looked after and protected from the
other prisoners as far as I'm concerned
trans women are one of those groups yeah
they're vulnerable but they do not
belong in a women's jail we do not
parachute out gang members or
I would say a separate Wing separate
Wing yeah yeah
um so uh how much where are we at with
gender self ID well here it's been
knocked on the head really in England in
Scotland it's going full steam ahead and
that's what the Scottish yes that's what
the protests that I was at yesterday was
about and I don't know how much you know
about Scottish politics but it basically
all just revolves around Independence
so you've not more than 90 of Scottish
people choose their party first and
foremost on what they call the
Constitutional question okay if you're
pro-independence you vote SNP if you're
against you split your vote between
Laboratory
um so that's why the s p have basically
a permanent lock on power makes them a
very bad government things will run very
badly in Scotland their health outcomes
are terrible their education outcomes
are terrible their spending is high and
very poor quality General Public
Services doesn't matter they're going to
be elected forevermore so it's quite
depressing really that you know there's
no accountability and for reasons that I
really can't speculate on Nicholas
sturgeon has decided that gender self ID
is going to be her big Legacy right
she's become convinced that that it's
and you know that it's a liberal and you
know it's the next big civil rights
battle to allow men to say they're women
so anyway we all tipped up outside
Hollywood yesterday with banners and you
know good sound system and there were
some very very stirring speeches you
know about there's a man running the
Edinburgh Rape Crisis Center a man who
says he's a woman you know and has said
that women who
very much like the idea of men and
women's right crisis centers that were
bigots and the bigots get raped too
um we need to re-educate ourselves about
our trauma not use the trauma as an
excuse there are men in women's prisons
in Scotland more than elsewhere in the
UK
um you know there's there's just Lots
there were lots of quite sad stories and
I mean it was a very stirring day but
yeah it's hard to see changing her mind
and she can do what she likes
um being Irish what's what's going on in
Ireland on on the on the uh the issue
yeah we foolishly brought in self ID
without any debate in 2015. so we've we
had three big sort of
what were presented as civil rights
issues in short succession and I think
two of them were and one of them was
um fraudulent
the other two were a gay marriage and a
more liberal abortion law
and so those two had big public debates
both of them required um referendums to
change our Constitution which had
already which described abortion
you know as not allowable at all and um
marriage is between a man and woman so
we had to we had to um change our
Constitution and that required a
referendum and there was a lot of public
debate and there were modern laws and it
was done really well it was just that
was democracy and action
but I don't think the founding fathers
of Ireland in 1920 whatever were
thinking that ever we would think that
men could be women or women men and so
they didn't write that down so it was
easy to just pass it and for reasons I
won't go into for legal reasons we
needed to allow some recognition of
trans identities to do with the European
Court of Human Rights
but it didn't have to be done the way it
was like the law just kept getting water
down and watered down and then finally
the law that went through in 2015 says
you fill in a form online
um you make a sworn statement in front
of a notary a send off your breaststroke
and they'll send you back another one
that says the opposite sex on us that's
it right
um can I bring up what's probably the
most controversial part of your book oh
I'm interested to know what you think is
the most confident you probably won't
find it controversial but uh I can
certainly imagine this paragraph okay
riling the trans activists more than any
other interesting um mainstream trans
activism are the desires of Rich
powerful males who want to be classed as
women everything I have written about
the harm to Children's bodies the loss
of women's privacy the destruction of
women's sports and the perversion of
language is collateral damage have you
had any pushback no no no no I mean
that's that's actually flown under the
many lies that are told about me so I'm
interested you think it's so
controversial but why that's
controversial though is is because it's
I I suppose it doesn't really allow for
the the what you've already explained
your sympathy with people for people
with gender dysphoria and stuff but it
it sort of writes off the whole movement
yeah really as a a
something nefarious rather than than
really accepting there's there's a
serious issue at the core of of people
who don't feel comfortable in their in
their bodies so I absolutely and the
book does not write off the issue that
there are people who are uncomfortable
in their bodies it writes off the idea
that that makes the members of the
opposite sex
those two things are just not logically
connected like there's just no reason to
say this man who wishes he wasn't a man
thereby is a woman we don't say that of
anything else I mean I'd like to be a
doctor or an airline pilot we would
never look at a black person or a black
child who says you know racism is awful
I wish I was white and then say well
you're trans white like it's incredibly
offensive actually
um so the movement the movement that I'm
talking about there that that paragraph
is about the movement for gender self-id
in law
process whereby a male person gets a
piece of paper that says he's female or
a female person gets a piece of paper
that says she's male
that's a really recent development
and it's not really a solution to gender
dysphoria like gender dysphoria could be
solved perhaps by getting used to the
body you're in for example
um so that movement's like why why does
anyone want to count legally as a member
of the opposite sex like the more I
think about it the more I think it's
extraordinary that that has been
pushed as a civil right why is it a
civil right there's nothing else that
I'm not that I can get a piece of paper
saying I am
and it turned I mean in my opinion you
know there are many sort of strands to
this you know like all big shifts you
could say it's a perfect storm like
those you know 10 or 12 different bits
to it but it would not have happened if
there weren't some rich powerful men who
wanted more than anything else to be
women so that's what I mean by that
paragraph that without that core this
would not have coalesced
um men and their sex drives it turns out
is a pretty powerful
uh shaper of the world men do all sorts
of things for their sex drives as
wonderful things art conquering
countries Etc but they do terrible
things there is a sexual side to some of
this is it called yes
um controversial label I mean I think
it's an arguable if you look in good
faith at the evidence that there are
some men For Whom the idea of being a
woman is a sexual
idea
so even if we don't go any further than
that even if we don't say that it's
actually a lot of the trans women
for some of them it clearly is so
autoginophilia just for someone who
doesn't know it's the Greek for love of
oneself as a woman and it's posited as
indeed another sexuality by the people
who researched it
um it's a sexuality that what turns a
man on is is The woman Inside is his
imagined self as a woman and again I'm
not saying all trans women
fall in this category but some do and
some will tell you they do and they've
written about it yes so we're sure that
there are men like this yes
[Music]
um
it's a
you know when you start to think that
some of the men who want to use women's
faces want to use them because they find
that sexy you're like you know why
should women have to put up with that
again yeah like I can see why the man
wants to do it I can't see why we're
meant to go along with it yeah
um so if I can tie this uh all together
now by going back to my uh original uh
opening uh uh words where I describe the
state of the creative Industries and how
the trans has been such it's been the
number one divisive issues it's the
issue on on this show I I've had James
Dreyfus the actor star of Thin Blue Line
and gimme gimme gimme and Notting Hill
speak about getting scrubbed off Doctor
Who as the master for having gender
critical opinions I've had Rosie K the
dancer choreographer describe how she
had was forced to resign from the
company that she built dance company and
to to form a new one and I wondered
whether you might have insight and this
is perhaps a difficult question is why
has this specific topic become as
fervent and febrile and
totemic and and and uh huge as it as it
has
I think it's because of what I just said
that it's about
people gaining recognition legal or
societal for exactly what they're not
so at its heart is a lie at it at its
heart there's the lie that a man can be
a woman or a woman can be a man or a
child can change sex
and you know as I think you know my PhD
is a mathematics I was an academic
before I became a journalist
and that's part of why I think I
recognized this is also strange at first
in that you know I'm used to logical
arguments and I'm used to theorems where
every step follows on from the previous
line and I see that as introducing zero
equals one into your mathematical
universe so you probably I don't know
how much you like maths at school but
you probably remember that you could do
the same thing to both sides of an
equation and it would still be true so
if you added four to both sides that was
fine if you divided both sides by two
that was fine yeah now suppose you've
got one lie zero equals one
okay you could add zero to one side of
the equation and one to the other and
you've got another lie then you double
this and you've got another lie again
you could do it twice you get a
different line the whole thing collapses
so if you imagine some crazy
mathematician who says there's this
whole world that's all mathematical and
it's all kind of interconnected but just
over here just there I'm just going to
allow zero to be one
it propagates it starts to ruin all the
other theorems and if you're very
attached to that lie that one over there
you're going to have to start getting
very angry with people who notice you're
going to have to say to them no it's not
propagating it's just that that has no
influence on anything else
but it does this is cognitive dissonance
isn't it and to actually confront that
difference means perhaps unpicking your
entire understanding of the world which
can be a very painful or you don't
confront it you just tell the other
person to shut up much easier much
easier option so if you're quite
attached to this thing here which you
might be for reasons that you know it's
it's psychologically very important to
you but loads of people who are very
supportive of trans ideology have no
particular skin in this game they've
just decided that this is the latest
virtue single it's the latest way to be
a good person they might be very
attached to the idea of themselves as
somebody who back in the day would have
been you know part of the Civil Rights
Movement would have been for fighting
for women suffrage would have you know
been really campaigning for gay marriage
but those things are done you want
something to do so you become quite
attached to this
and then anyone who says to you but look
you know if you allow men to be women
over here
you're going to have rapists in women's
jails over there you're going to ruin
women's sport you get very angry yeah
and you must silence people it's the
only way to maintain the LIE is to let
it is to make it impossible for anyone
to talk about it that's why it's
totalitarian you have to control the
language you have to keep people silent
you have to cancel anyone who does it
says anything about it in order that
other people are too scared to speak
about it that's why because it's a lie
but if I can finish on a personal
question then have you been canceled
because you are now very public facing I
I said before we started speaking that
having read uh widely on on this
particular particular topic I would
recommend your book trans as the perfect
starting Place pretty much authoritative
on issue certainly in Britain uh uh for
people who wanted to an entry point and
um I wondered now that you're so public
in your stance as gender critical if
you've been canceled and what uh push
back you've had
I mean this word canceled kind of isn't
very well defined is it so I'll just
answer what the response has been so
I I didn't know it was going to be so
controversial when I found it so I was
already quite a long way in before I
realized that I was putting my career at
risk but I was lucky and the editor of
The Economist is not a coward
zany doesn't like bullies and she does
like free speech and she does not like
people telling her what she should put
on her paper and that turned out to be
enough
even though she didn't really agree with
me so
I didn't lose my job and I'm not
actually working at The Economist at the
moment I'm on a leave of absence I had
to decide what to do when that year ends
I'm working with sex matters at the
moment as a campaign group sort of a
startup and non-profit that's working
towards charitable status and Maya Force
data that I mentioned who lost her job
for saying Sex Is Real at a think tank
still Boggle when I say that sentence um
she's the executive director I'm one of
the founders it's a bunch of lawyers
basically
looking at the way that we deal with sex
in law and everyday life so I'm working
there now with them at the moment
um I mean I think it's the most
interesting thing I've ever done
um
I guess because I don't have skin in
this game I don't care what people say
like I don't have a trans child I'm not
trans identified
you know I'm earning a living that they
can't get at certainly people tried
certainly people have tried you know to
get me unpublished to go after anyone
who's connected with me
you know and you've had problems in
America being published yeah I mean the
book didn't get picked up by any
American publisher though kindly Simon
and Chester distributed it and feedback
was very much that people thought it
would sell but that they didn't want the
grief inside the office
I didn't get anyone so that's an
interesting specific feedback because
the more obvious critique would be that
it's pretty British specific to British
law not exclusively and so actually to
an American audience that might be
harder but if the actual criticism is no
we didn't want pushback from the young
people in the business or you know
that's that's a separate issue so but
this is what happens in publishing
Publishers are all cowards well nearly
all cowards my Publisher's lovely but
they careful
I'm sorry I just it's funny it's
addictive saying what you think it turns
out
it's so enjoyable being honest
um yeah like I wrote it to be quite
International like I went to Canada I
went to the US I did I grounded
different bits of it in different
countries you know so the um the sports
stuff in one place the employment stuff
and another the school stuff and another
the bathroom stuff and another so it
could have sold in America Americans are
very parochial in their publishing
industry though
so maybe it's just that but the feedback
was no some from some of them no this
will sell but too much grief inside the
office there's no one book from a
first-time author that's worth that
grief like if it's Jordan Peterson or JK
Rowling you tell the kids to shut up
um yeah so so I didn't get a publisher
and I didn't get anyone pick up the
audiobook for the same reason there are
about 10 companies that produce
audiobooks in this country and not one
of them was willing to do it so my son
recorded it in the understeer's office
um
little coverage where the washing
machine is
we hung we hung duvets around she's a
sound engineer so he came home for a
week and he recorded me doing it there
and it's the one and only audiobook
that's been put out by my print
Publishers great so we got it out there
anyway well done well uh Helen Joyce
thank you so much for your time I
recommend your book trans to readers and
sure later up on that conversation
fascinating and I wish you all the best
as you continue your journey speaking
your mind freely fearlessly and I enjoy
I I look forward to enjoying what you
have to say next thank you very much for
having me in
foreign
[Music]
[Music]